[Music]
right now there's no need for memories
[Music]
yes guys
how are we doing
[Music]
hello hello thanks for coming chicago
could you do me a big favor as soon as
you're wearing the most wonderful hoodie
in the world could you come over here
for just one second could you take this
microphone and carefully place it in
there in case anyone wants to talk to us
oh what are three of them i'm very
echoey in this mic maybe we can turn
down the echo in my mind it sounds like
i'm living in a cave
um
we just got off a flight from uh la to
chicago
where they warned us that there would be
thunderstorms the actual the pilot came
on the phone on the little
thing normally he speaks from the
cockpit you know the pilot's like hey
we're going to go to 35 000 feet and
you're like yeah i don't mind just get
me wherever you want to go yeah
and he came on the phone do you remember
stood in front of us and said hi guys
there's there's a threat of
thunderstorms and
this and that and i looked at elijah who
i sat next to and i was like
i mean i've never been on a plane where
a pilot says that there's going to be a
strong
threat of thunderstorms this is we're
going to be in for a a bit of a pickle
here and it was
smooth sailing right done
well you were doing that yeah
i was reading a book
very
very kindly bought
for me by uh john monahan who's sitting
on my right here wow
yeah and uh the book was the body
by bill bryson has anyone read the body
by bill bryson well i tell you it's
wonderful no one in the audience wow
it's a great book if you have a body
then read it because
it tells you all about it how it works
and all this and that and the bet i was
reading right yeah right
was talking about
the world war ii
and there was a guy in a lancaster
bomber and he was the he was the the
back gunner on this lancaster bomber and
the the room in these little planes was
so small that he
the back gunner wasn't allowed to put a
parachute on
so they get hit
and the plane's on fire
and he goes oh i better get out then and
he gets out of his little bit and he
goes to get his parachute tom
his parachutes on fire
and he thought to myself well he thought
to himself not to you not to me
i wasn't even born at this point
but he thought to himself
i'm going to jump out anyway because i'm
in abundant plane
i'm better out there than in here yeah
yeah yeah so he said he jumped out and
he said after a little while he said
i didn't even feel like i was moving i
was just kind of like
you know
he said it was quite peaceful really
and he thought he says i didn't want to
die but he said i was you know i was i
was in a plane at in the war there was a
good there was a chance for sure so he
did put his mind to it
it sort of he says i don't know if i i
passed out or what he says but next
thing i know i went through these trees
landed in a snowy hill
sitting down
nothing but a sword bum
and a couple of scratches my god
so the tree and the snow broke his fall
we don't know dumb incredible or maybe
it just wasn't his time
after the cosmic very cosmic after the
war he got a job in a chemical factory
he was unscrewing a thing accidentally
covered himself in sulfuric acid
still didn't die
what a life
anger it's not over
then one day he gets to work he's
walking into his bit and a metal pole
that weighed like half a ton hit him in
the head
he still didn't die jesus
he died quietly in his bed when he was
67. oh good for him good for him
the things you learn on the friendship i
know
okay let's bring it back to go on go on
just before we go on to the next thing
just staying with planes do you remember
when we were making the trilogy of films
called the lord of the rings what a
fantastic series of films well we were
down in new zealand and um
we had to go all over the place you know
to be up mountains and on rivers and all
that and one time we had to uh
we had to be somewhere and and
all the planes were being used so pete
jackson arranged us to be on like this
1945
bomber planes you remember that that
they had
i didn't go out the back by the way and
fall through a tree
but
they they'd made it into like a
commercial plane
so the the stewards and stewardesses
were dressed in like 1945 you know like
as if they were in the war or whatever
but the plane had been done
well
as if they were in the war well they're
in the war no they're not acting like
they're in the war they're in it surely
this is us in new zealand
remember and they think me i thought you
know
not really i thought you were giving us
a
second world war story this is us in new
zealand and bombers and stuff do you
remember where we're on now you do
realize that when we were in new zealand
making lord rings that that wasn't the
second world war oh i do know that i
know it felt like the second world war
okay so go on this is we're not saying
do you remember this and we're wrong
and you know like a plane sits like that
now but this one sat like that could
have just had the little wheel on the
back but we took off and we're off and
it was like fun and we're going to the
south island and everybody's drinking
wine and like whoa this is great
and we went into this turbulence and it
was just going whoa and everybody's
still oh this is exciting and then it
dropped like 200 feet or whatever it was
it just went whoa
and all this wine was on the roof
and stuff no i do remember this bit
because i dropped my red wine i was
devastated
it's a lovely glass of merlot and do you
remember the stewardess who was dressed
in 1945 garb was being sick
she was being sick in the back i think
she passed out i think she fainted and
we were like oh that's concerning yeah
because then you know and then the pilot
so it was a small enough plane like
billy said the pilot the plane was small
enough the the pilot opened the back
door so let's say this is the pilot
flying the plane he opened the door and
he turned on and went everyone's sitting
down and shut up that's right and we
were like oh god because we're having
fun at that point whoa red wine
everywhere everyone's having a laugh oh
it's a bit bumpy and then the pilot was
like everyone sit down and shut up and
we were like okay i remember i was
sitting next to you and you you went and
i mean you went and the laughing stopped
yeah
that was a skit that was the scariest
plane thing i've ever that's definitely
the scariest playing experience i've
ever had orlando was was sat near me too
and he grabbed my hand and uh he was
pretty close to crying orlando oh i was
like oh god what we're gonna do and i
was like we'll be okay we'll be okay
even if we're not gonna be okay let's
pretend like we're gonna be okay because
why does it why does it serve us i think
that we won't be okay when running a
business your employees can create all
kinds of interesting situations maybe
somebody isn't showing up when they're
supposed to well you can talk to bambi
with bambi get access to your own
dedicated hr manager starting at just 99
per month they're available by phone
email and real-time chat so onboarding
and terminations run smoothly team
members reach peak performance and your
business stays compliant with changing
hr regulations and with bambi's hr
autopilot you'll automate important hr
practices like setting policies training
and feedback you'll have your own
dedicated hr manager us-based person
dedicated to your business giving you
access to the hr expertise and personal
touch you need hr managers can easily
cost 80 grand a year but bambi starts at
99
a month schedule your free conversation
today and see how much bambi can take
off your plate
it's definitely true hr issue business
owners currently have challenges with
things like what do employees have to do
when remote workers move locations or
employee attendance issues whether
they're coming to work or not and they
can also sometimes deal with how do you
attract and keep top talent for small
businesses visit
bambi.com onion right now spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash onion bambi.com
slash onion
no one has a business like yours with
all its strengths and challenges to
succeed you need a hiring partner that
adapts to your needs you need indeed
indeed is the hiring platform where you
can attract interview and hire all in
one place instead of spending hours on
multiple job sites searching for
candidates with the right skills
indeed's a powerful hiring partner that
can help you do it all find great talent
faster through time-saving tools like
indeed instant match assessments and
virtual interviews
with instant match over 80 percent of
employers get quality candidates whose
resume on indeed matches their job
description the moment they sponsor a
job according to indeed data u.s one of
the things that i love about indeed is
the indeed assessment so indeed
assessments help take all the stress out
of the interview process your candidates
get to prove themselves before the
interview so that you and them can dive
deeper into talking about what is
important even better indeed's the only
job site where you only pay for
applications that meet your must-have
requirements when you sponsor an indeed
post in the us you're three times more
likely to get a higher according to
indeed data join more than three million
businesses worldwide that use indeed to
hire great talent fast start hiring now
with a 75 sponsored job credit to
upgrade your job post at indeed.com
onion all for good for a limited time
claim your 75 dollar credit now at
indeed.com slash onion indeed.com onion
terms and conditions apply need to hire
you need indeed hey phil what should we
do some housekeeping
[Music]
oh i was really excited about my
harmonies there it was lovely
i actually like i was in the gym the
other day
slightly messed up
i would say the bottom of my boob that
the top of my rib cage it was really
painful i was like leaning into
something right to try and like
push something down it was kind of it
was like a two-handed
like or 20 back thing yeah bombing thing
and it really like smashed into the
bottom of my my booby do you think it's
do you think it's your intercostal
muscle maybe but it's so
i'll have a look at that book i've got
and i'll see if it tells me the body by
bill bryson which i bought for you um
but you know what i did i did this thing
that they recommend in terms of like if
you if you have an injury or you think
that
if you think you that you've injured
yourself all that you think that
possibly later on this might turn into
an injury a red
that what happens is the brain
sends a message let's say to that part
of the body
bottom of my boob top top of my rib cage
to say oh i think we're injured
and you rib cage
bottom of your boob sends a message back
saying yeah it feels sore
we need to be mindful of that now at
that point
a lot of people in the medical industry
say what you need to do is stop those
messages from going round and round in a
circle yeah because the brain says we're
injured the body says we're injured and
it goes backwards and forwards and it
creates this kind of
cycle of tension and and injury what you
want to do is relax be like yeah that
hurt
but let's just kind of relax realize
that we're okay and then the body can
start to heal so what i did was after i
injured myself a couple of hours later
when it was really hurting really
hurting i would use the word smiting
it smoked me yeah it smoked i had been
smoking
i just meditated for about 30 minutes on
the boob on my booby
i was like it's okay it hurts it's not
gonna get any worse
it will probably get better if you just
relax and be okay with the fact that it
hurts and you know what
it didn't do anything no it i it
actually it actually helped so there we
go now which part is of your what is
that system called like is it the is it
the paris parasympathetic no it's easier
an easier word than that because i was
just reading about it in the body like
if you get a flu what is it in your body
that fights it is it i thought it was
the sympathetic nervous system no what's
it called hello
yeah your immune system i'm so sorry
about me yeah i was too loud that
immune system yes the immune system i
would just read all about that as well
i'll tell you about that later but let's
do it here i'll read a message here and
then we're gonna we're gonna very
quickly get to uh the audience so if
anyone has questions in the audience
please feel free to ask us questions so
a a question here from jerry c
in chicago i'm not sure illinois i'm
assuming that jerry c isn't here no
there's no one here um
so jerry c said the legendary robert de
niro
the famous
chicago gangster in the untouchables i
was wondering who gene and denver dave's
favorite movie gangsters are in movies
see you in chicago so maybe they are
coming to chicago well i mean is this
the kind of place where we could have
gene and denver they feel like i mean
that means
a place of uh worship
is everybody over 18
is anyone under 18
i think
i mean hey gene
what do you like they're mad you like
them gangsters
i like the uh i like you like what you
like
like anybody else i like the
untouchables of course you like your
untouchables i like those uh good fellas
the good fellows are the good fellows uh
what do you call it
mean streets
it's a fantastic movie
what i like
what do you like i like i like the
goodwill hunting i like the uh kings of
new york do you like the little guy i
like the l what that little you know
you know what i really like my favorite
thing kill me on a friday night like
give myself a little uh single scoop of
ice cream i love that
vanilla
yeah it's a vanilla thing with a little
uh
i like a little girl like a girl like a
cat like a caramel
you know like a little what's your
little
camel camera thing i love that i like to
settle down in front of my uh little
couch there with a little single scoop
and some camel
hey what i like the movie pretty woman
you like that
i like that julia roberts you know she
goes from a lady she's confused she's
like you know she's gotta make a living
she's on the street she's doing a thing
she meets a guy she's like hey i kind of
like you so i kind of like you like he's
like i don't want to leave that behind
he's like leave it behind hang out with
me she's all right i'll do that and then
later on that other girl and she like
she's like
hey yo you're gonna leave me behind
she's like let's see what your gear you
know i mean he's in the gigolo thing
he's the officer the gentleman what you
gonna do
the pretty woman yeah i like the pretty
woman i never she i watch that yeah that
that uh julia roberts she looks like she
sleeps with like a coat hanger in her
mouth yeah she's got a big mouth she
puts two billy a book guys fantastic
she's amazing
thank you jerry c what a fantastic
question
um
oh we've got a question here about a
classic dish tiffany t tiffany t from
chicago illinois hey by the way don
if this was
a map of the united states of america
yeah florida
new york city
california yeah
where is chicago chicago well we're here
so i haven't have looked into this but i
might not get this right but i feel like
chicago is kind of
there
where there
no there
is it that far over i might wait wait
this way
that way
i'll give you seven out of ten tom it
wasn't bad but it wasn't very good thank
you audience members tiffany t
tiffany
she's from chicago as well well tiffany
t says ya all which i thought was more
southern yeah you're all it means you
all you all
ever try deep dish pizza it's a chicago
staple if so what's your favorite and do
you like it better than new york style
careful if you're answering this in
chicago now that's a great
comment there because a lot of people in
chicago are very inclined to the deep
dis pizza
pizza
pizza
he's from chicago johnny johnny clues
was going to come we were going to have
a special guest and just so you guys
know it was going to be johnny clues
unfortunately he got diarrhea he's uh
i mean
he actually described it as explosive
diarrhea
he's on the toilet coming out of both
ends
he says yeah both ends so he couldn't
make it but he he wanted us to try a
deepest pizza pizza um
he told us where but i i can't find it i
think i think i've had a deep dish pizza
you can't see that i can't
it makes me feel panicky i think i've
had a deep dish pizza before
i don't think i really liked it
sorry
that now what i know
tons of gas you've seen
i shouldn't say
tons of gas in the audience i think
my thing is that
everything all right no sorry i'm just
trying to find john's thing
my my thing is that i think i might want
my pizza to be a little
lighter and obviously
the whole vibe of a deep dish pizza is
that each slice is kind of a bit of a
thing you know i mean like a few slices
and
you're in trouble have you had a deep
dish
pizza i have and i think if you're
hungry it's good and if you get a good
dough
because you don't want a bad day
oh my god
they're absolutely filthy they're still
they're good for seeing stuff not really
i'll give them a claim for you thanks
very much
no i can't read this
[Laughter]
hang on preamble preamble
thank you i think he would go
all right there we go was it the art of
pizza
art a-r-t
i think john says that's the place to
get it yeah
art yeah we were gonna have john come on
we did say to john as a chicago uh
native
you decide what we bring on we've
already established jardinera which
might be my all-time favorite thing that
we yes good applause though what's that
from here
is from chicago oh my my all-time
favorite thing that we've ever had on
yes over there in the back
[Music]
lakers
candy floss
probably a big jar in a month i love it
in pasta in rice eggs scrambled eggs yes
madam
have you never tried it always
it's a chicago store where's louisiana
it's my hand
um it is basically a combination of
carrots celery and chili peppers
in
olive oil and obviously the oil gets
hotter and hotter the longer that it's
in the chili so you end up with really
hot chili oil which is fantastic and you
can use for cooking but
the vegetables carrots celery anyone
else know what what else in there chilis
jalapenos cauliflower lovely stuff hang
on
i feel like i mean we're being shot
there
someone's shooting us the vegetables
cauliflower
carrots
um
it's fantastic with scrambled eggs i
taught uh elijah my scrambled egg dish
yesterday so elijah was cooking for his
young family yesterday and when we were
in denver i said to elijah i have
an amazing scrambled egg
it's not even a recipe it's a method
it's not even a different way of cooking
well actually it is a different way of
cooking scrambled eggs but it's not it
includes just scrambled eggs that's it
and i was like it's just a way of
cooking it you get as much air in it as
possible so i was talking elijah through
it yesterday and he smashed it and he
loved it and he and he said he'll never
cook scrambled eggs again and i said to
him if you want to take it to the next
level
get a jar of chardonnaire and when
you're finished with those scrambled
eggs just put a tiny little dollop of
jardiner on top it's insane yeah it's
changed my life but if we were going to
have deep dish pizza where would we get
it in chicago
we'll fight fight fight giorgio's wow
what
geno's illuminati what
phenos whoa there's a lot of g knows i'm
going to go to genoa is it nearby
do they deliver
what should i have on it
no he doesn't eat meat he doesn't eat
well you've been eating a little bit but
i've been like eating meat but no you're
not a massive meat i'm i'm eating always
a massive meal
i don't know what happened i was
vegetarian for 15 years and then i i
don't know a cow looked at me the wrong
way or something
don't know what happened it can happen
it can happen we've got our final
question here before we move on to um
let's have questions from the audience
just calm down i mean they're all here
why relax for a second oh please dom so
john james from oak park in illinois
chicago said i'm not sure if you've seen
the chicago flag didn't even know that
chicago had a flag sorry
and he said perhaps i'm biased i think
it's one of the coolest flags in the
united states i was wondering what your
favorite flags are
and why
well well that's a good question on
flags i
i enjoy a japan flag i know billy does
too the uh the land of the uh rising sun
that's a wonderful flag um i enjoy a
cameroon flag they have a wonderful flag
there's a
shag shack you're drunk flag of chicago
four stars does it do we know what the
four stars represent
hang on
well everyone just calm down for a
second
why don't you go we've got the
the four stars represent four
significant events in the history of
chicago we've established the chicago
fire please go on my dear come on you
know the other three if not you can just
give us what you have yes and
okay chicago five does anyone else know
yes
could you please go over to the mic
before billy assaults you
the colombian exposition for dearborn
and then the world's fair
fantastic the chicago world's fair
uh wait was it for fort dearborn what
what what's fort dearborn
it was like the first fort built in
chicago and it was like the first like
i like called like colony kind of thing
going on brilliant and then one before
that my darling sorry the colombian
exposition because we had two worlds
fair so it's the colombian exposition
then the world's fair
clearly a very intelligent woman there
lovely
oh hold on two blue stripes would you
like to approach the mic
hang on
wonder woman coming over
thank you
yes
come on john i stand corrected
this is the wrong room to get that stuff
sorry about that
i only saw you for a flash second uh the
two blue lines are for the two rivers
that we have
which are hold on which are two rivers
that run through chicago yes i know this
because i'm good on rivers it's the
harry and the [ __ ]
no was i close
no
chicago river and my now that i'm up
here any
boxer over anything yeah
but the two blue lines represent the two
main rivers and here's something about a
river that runs through chicago you
might not know it's one of the few
rivers that runs backwards yes it is
it's one of the craziest things about
chicago that all the water runs away
from the direction that you would expect
and that means time goes the opposite
way yeah if you go in that river hey
billy it's been hot hasn't it yeah
roasting hot and one of my little life
hacks is to have a liquid iv in the
morning oh we love it especially before
the gym you've been bulking i have i've
been going to the gym quite a lot too
it's important to stay hydrated liquid
iv fantastic little sachet you pour your
powder into your water some amazing
flavors they've got concord grape lemon
lime pina colada tropical punch just to
mention a few of the 10 flavors that
they have i always have a couple of
packets there dom because i love them as
you say first thing in the morning if
you waken up and you feel like oh i feel
a bit dehydrated hey maybe you've had a
glass of wine maybe i've had a couple of
glasses of wine lovely or if you're at
the gym i just sip on a bottle that have
some liquid iv and some water fantastic
some of my favorites i like i like when
they're refreshing like the lemon and
lime
grape watermelon my wife likes guava
acai there's a pina colada one very
tight pina colada so there's all sorts
of different flavors it's fantastic it
comes in little pouches so you don't
have to measure anything out liquid iv
is amazing yeah it contains five
essential vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and
vitamin c it has three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports drink
and it's made with premium ingredients
and it's non-gmo free from gluten dairy
free soy free fantastic
grab your liquid iv and built nationwide
at costco or you can get 15 off when you
go to liquidive.com and use the code
onion at the checkout that's 15
of anything you order when you shop
better hydration today using the promo
code onion at liquidive.com
well william you and i travel a lot
we've been very lucky in our lives we're
in and out of airports international and
domestic we're in hotels all the time
and let me tell you one of the first
things that i do when i get to an
airport or a hotel i turn on my
expressvpn and it's just one click of
the button you're totally secure well
you should do that dom because i tell
you anytime you join an unencrypted
network whether you're in a cafe a hotel
an airport
all your online data is not secure
anyone can steal your personal data
passwords financial details
and it doesn't take much technical
knowledge to hack someone all somebody
needs is some cheap hardware and they
can get all your data and your data is
valuable yeah hackers make up to a
thousand dollars per person selling your
information on the dart web oh i don't
like the sound of that yeah
it's a fantastic thing expressvpn like i
said very easy to use one click of the
button it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet hackers don't have a chance to
steal any of your sense of information
and it works on all devices phones
laptops tablets and you can stay secure
everywhere you go feel happy anywhere
you are exactly keep your passwords and
you can bank online it's a great thing
expressvpn
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com.com
and you can get an extra three months
free expressvpn.com
is there any questions does anybody get
any questions that they'd like us to
answer or at least try billionaires
there's a microphone there yes let's do
three questions before we do a tongue
twister which i think you'll be awful
yeah
um billy and i were saying backstage
uh before the show began we don't need
we don't need to just do three you guys
can just line up what we could do but we
were saying in such an intimate
incredible audience we should try and
answer as many questions as we can from
the people in the room do you know what
i mean
so
my darling hi
uh did you know shawn aston has a
picture of that flight to wellington in
his book
could i see it please
i did not know is there red wine on the
ceiling hang on a second
there it is
is that the one that's there you go
yeah yeah
it was and there's your makeup artist
yeah that's lenovo linoleum
that's that's sean astin's little
daughter
flying from wellington to tiano
in a 1942 dc-3 this was always a scary
flight but in this particular trip we
hit a storm and made an unscheduled
landing in queenstown there was a
terrible smell of tears
can't believe sean wrote that yeah
hey hello
thank you uh dressed as princess leia in
uh a new hope
sometimes i get it right
this is a very deep cut oh
but
in the fan commentary which i've watched
about a thousand times you guys talked
about making up a complex game to prank
i think elijah but it was definitely one
of your um
cast mates
and you also fooled him into doing a
fake interview what's the best prank you
guys pulled on the lord of the rings set
well
i mean we did mess around a little bit
but the the best prank is hans jensen
right yeah
yes that's this killing joke i call it
it's the best prank i've ever seen we're
in the moment this is this is what's
beautiful about those those moments and
someone was asking me about this the
other day at a convention
uh
in terms of how that all happened and i
just said it just it just happened it
just
came out of nowhere
billy and i were approached by a
publicist that i believe was working for
new line because we were working for new
line at the time doing press
in
europe and elijah was in new york doing
saturday night live and he had been
rehearsing
but a few hours or a couple of hours
before the rehears before the show of
saturday night live he was doing press
so he was elijah was expected to do a
few hours of press for lord the rings
and then go into his performance on
saturday night live and it was going to
take him into
midnight one in the morning and he was
jet-lagged and he was exhausted like we
all were from doing a press thing and
she actually said to billy and i can you
just go into that room and say hello can
you just go in and say hello say hey
elijah we love you how's it going are
you good oh yeah we're getting the same
questions as you and
you know it's crazy and we can't wait to
see you in wherever london sydney japan
wherever we were going and we were like
yeah yeah of course we'll do it and she
left and billy and i were chatting
didn't think anything of it
and then when she came back i remember
saying to her
wait
so how does it work
elijah chats to us we chat to him and
she was like yeah i i lied to chats to
uh to you guys but he can't see you all
he can see is a camera you can see him
on
a tv screen but he can only see a camera
pointing towards him and i was like
oh
[Laughter]
and
to give billy his credit because you
know billy always tries to tries to live
in a place of not doing anyone any harm
i was like i'm gonna
mess with him here and billy's like you
know what
you you should do that
i i do remember that i do remember
because i was like come on let's go for
it no so i think we said if both of us
went and he would know he would probably
know yeah because he'd be like it's
normally one person that you're doing
something something there's suddenly two
people
know who it is billy was like you know
what go do it so i went in with nothing
with nothing i just i pretended like i
had papers and i pretended like i i had
something to present
and what i was what i was desperately
trying to do in those questions was
see if elijah could work out it was me
because even though i was talking in
this like german accent
oh my god i figured if i would ask him a
question that only i would know
he would say aight is dumb
but he never did and
and i was i was i ramped up the
questions to see if he would figure it
out and he would he never figured it out
and and the whole when will you wear
wigs thing
this so this happened from
elijah and billy and shawn and orlando
and vigo and i would would jump in and
out of these interviews for years for
two or three years running and it would
be
us in la in in london in berlin in japan
in sydney and we would all have we would
all be in different states of hair cuts
and sometimes elijah or i or billy would
be in a a hobbit wig and then not a
hobbit wig and then a hoodie and all
this kind of stuff so what i wanted to
say to elijah at the start of those
questions as a confused german
interviewer was how does that work how
does your hair go from short to long and
long to short and i wanted to allow you
to like
be annoyed by the fact that well clearly
we're wearing wigs and
it's i'm not frodo i'm a different
person so i said
do you wear wigs
and he said no i do not
and i thought
yes he does i've
i've seen him wear wigs so i go
have you worn wigs knowing that he had
werewig worn wigs
and he goes no i have not
and i think yes you have i've been on
set with you you've worn wigs for like a
year and a half
so i go
will you wear wigs like
is there an is there a chance in the
future when you might wear wigs since
i've seen you do it in our present
and elijah goes
baby
[Music]
and then i go
then will you bear veg and then elijah
goes
so it honestly just organically happened
and it was not it was not something that
i came up with but i was fully aware
that this joke had somehow spiraled out
of complete control
in the moment and it was
it was one of my favorite moments to be
in the moment because it just happened
and it just happened to be funny you
know very fun thank you guys you're the
funniest and best habits thank you
that's so sweet thank you
hi hello
sorry 12 year old me right now is going
insane
um my question is like obviously i liked
one of the rings since i was a kid i
read the books everyone was reading
harry potter and i said why would you
read that when you can read tolkien um
so the battles are always my favorite
can you just talk about like doing the
battle scenes whether it was maurya
helms deep middle planner fields i want
to hear all about that because it's so
badass the annoying thing is that we
weren't allowed to be any good yeah you
know
we had to be rubbish at swordplay and
uh and i was actually i used to do
competitions i used to do so
billy is probably objectively the best
swordsman in the fellowship and you had
to be probably the
second or third probably worst yeah
maybe maybe the worst yeah but we were
lucky enough that we got to work with um
bob anderson who taught everyone from
you know darth vader errol flynn
princess bride he did all that swordplay
and uh just sitting talking to him was
some of my favorite times
and he he was always laughing because i
wasn't allowed to do anything
he's like yeah you know hit someone with
a stone or something and i'm like ah
yeah
it was a drag also i think pete was very
very um
aware that the hobbits represented this
sense of innocence in war
so for the four of us to show up on the
battlefield in a way that you know maybe
the two of us even because frodo and sam
really didn't they were on their own
really journey they never got involved
in the in the planes of battle i think
he wanted mary and pippin
to be very kind of just
disorientated confused
completely kind of you know
lost in the moment in the same way that
maybe
a naive private in the army might be so
like billy said we find ourselves
in regalia in armor with a helmet with a
sword and pete is saying just look like
you don't know what you're doing and
we're like yeah we can do that
i didn't like my helmet either i was
always trying to take it off and he's
like pete really likes helmets
he loves you and one time
i went to weta to get my helmet you know
which ended up being that sort of
gundorian
but as it's written in the book it says
it has wings on the side magnificent
wings and all that and they made this
this helmet that had wings like
that
and i don't have a very big head
and i thought it was a joke
and i was like and these guys are
amazing the stuff that they made i put
this helmet on it was like that
i saw it i saw it it was brilliant billy
actually said to me i think this is a
window i thought i thought it was a joke
but
it wasn't and that they they'd made it
like it was written in the book but but
then they just made little wings sort of
metal ones i mean with the original if
they'd have thrown you off a high hill i
think you would have made your way i
could have flown like a paper airplane
that's probably what happened to that
guy in world war two
thank you for your question thank you
better what's done we'll do i think just
one question should we do other things
why don't we do why don't we do
questions during our billion dominate
the world we could do we could get a
combo we could eat and but i really want
to do the um tongue twister because i
feel as if your mouth isn't working
great no my mouth is terrible today i
had one so i think i might win this do
we have it do we have that i do well
darling darling before we do it
what's your name and where'd you come
okay my name is lana i'm from detroit so
my my hand is a map of michigan i'm from
here lovely stuff and michigan that's
what people say isn't it they say it's
like a hand michigan michigan ah do you
know i've got relatives in michigan so i
used to go quite a lot
i know michigan really well but i call
it michigan yeah
um where uh mount clemens yep you know
man clemens yeah not my side of town but
yeah definitely i know where my usually
oh don't he doesn't
that i know in a city that my family
came from that i've never been to
there's a german town there isn't that
frankie moose what i think it's frankie
moose franken frankenmus and they have
an all year round christmas store oh
wonderful
don't even yeah
let's see there he is there's santa
claus the sanity clause well
do you have a question yes um hopefully
i don't know if any of anybody would
remember this from the an episode of the
podcast um
i hope the funniest thing i think i
heard on the podcast was billy talking
about this elderly gentleman on antiques
roadshow yes and and the clove of garlic
if you haven't heard it you look it up
um i'm not going to repeat what you said
but if anybody followed a clip of this
anywhere online because i searched for
it
does anyone know what she's talking what
was your name again sorry lana what
lana's talking about honestly i think
billy's made this up i did not make it
up
there's a show in britain called the
antiques roadshow
what
yeah they have it here they have they
have it here and people come and they
bring something you know oh i've got
these i've got this kettle that my gran
left me or or egg cups or a painting and
the guy looks at it and goes um this was
made in 1870 do you have to make that
noise
and then
everybody just wants to know how much
it's worth that's oh anybody watching
and then they'll say that's worth four
hundred dollars and the guy's like oh it
cost me twenty two dollars
okay but one time i was watching it and
a guy was there
with like some pottery or something
and then he started and and he was an
old man he was maybe 80 and he said you
look very healthy he says i've never
been sick
a day in my life
and the guy says
that's amazing how what do you what do
you
how is that how can that happen
and
and he says i take a clove of garlic
every morning
and i put up my bum
and you could see the antiques roadshow
guy was a bit shocked because
he's just wanting to tell people how
much pottery is worth you know
so he didn't really know what to say and
he said
a single clove of garlic
yes
he says i take a single clove of garlic
and i put it up my bum
and i remember watching it saying and i
had a lot more questions
but the antique roadshow guy didn't he
just left it at that
and uh no one seems to be able to find
this footage yeah i think he's made it
up i've not made that
you could not make that up no you're
good
you would hope not i won't explain that
well what a fantastic tongue twister
tongue twister thank you my dear we will
get to these questions
what's your name and where did you come
from uh beverly
i came from louisiana
louisiana now if you don't mind uh
beverly beverly yes beverly uh if you
don't mind beverly we need a judge
whenever we do uh talking to ourselves
because dom is very very hard on me very
hard
very straight
would you like to join us on stage oh my
god come on come with us what you need
to make though won't you mine
[Applause]
now beverly
the rules are beverly we're going to
read this tongue twister we're going to
read it are we going to read it three
times we're going to read it three times
in a row now beverly if anyone gets any
of these words wrong you have to say
no that doesn't work for me you can wait
till the end if you want or while
they're doing it you can say no that's
not right and if someone gets to the end
three times in a row then we're gonna
find out how we do on the clock and it's
a competition between billy knight we
would also really like it if you would
play with us so maybe you can do the
third goal
yeah you'll be all right
who's going first up well
dealer's choice
i'll go first i don't know william i
think you should i'm feeling quite
articulate yes you're quite [ __ ]
tonight
okay three two one yeah and then i'll do
it don't okay and and we're okay on the
clock over there everyone wonderful
stuff team okay i'll give you three two
one and
that no no i'll give you that right and
then what i'm going to give you is a
little gift what's that is it go
i'm going to give you three i don't want
to go so just three two one because go
will be me saying f okay here we go
ready yep
definitely if there's any faults in his
diction i'll leave that with you
remember i have an accent simply
just simply say no
okay
ready bills yes
three two one if two witches were
watching two watches which witch would
watch which watch if two witches were
watching two watches which witch would
watch which watch if two witches were
watching two watches which witch would
watch which watch fantastic
14 seconds that was perfect
we're getting we're getting a go from uh
beverly there that's 100 i got how fast
was that 14 seconds nobody could believe
it could be done in 14 seconds
nobody could believe that the glasses
nearly flew off then i got so excited
you're a little bit of a mathematician
but do you know what 14 divided by 3 is
yeah of course i do
anyone
12.
it can't be 12. you did it in 14 seconds
4.666
666 4.666 ago all right i'm ready are
you ready are you really ready i'm ready
a three two one
if two witches were watching two watches
which which would watch which watch if
two [ __ ] were watching two watches
which which would watch which watch if
two witches were watching which watches
which which would watch which one
what
[Applause]
it was going well as well it was good
what did i do beverly everything was
wrong you added an extra s really yeah
all right i lost track after that okay
all right beverly my god are you ready
yes
three two one
if two witches were watching two watches
which which would watch which watch if
two witches were watching which oh
[ __ ] out
what do you think of that beverly
this is your last goal yeah i understand
there is no go after this one
three two one if two witches were
watching two watches which which would
watch which watch if two witches were
watching two watches which which would
watch which watch if two witches were
watching two watches which which would
watch two
[Applause]
the champions
[Music]
beverly that's the first time he's
beating me now over to beverly do you
want to take this match or this one
would you like it to be working okay
yeah that works on it
you ready for this sure i'm not ready
for this
let's go all right
lovely what a lovely warm chicagoan
applause there okay beverly ready
three two one if two witches were
watching two watches which which would
watch which watch if two witches are
watching no no
wait
no that was famed um
it's just because i lost
like let's get the let's get this
straight you cannot win now okay there
is no winning for you here so um
i apologize i apologize as well i'm so
sorry that one doesn't count
sorry beverly all right here we go bills
three two one if two witches were
watching two watches which which would
watch which watch if two witches were
watching two watches which which would
watch which watch if two witches were
watching two watches which which would
watch which watch
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you tremendous thank you beverly
yes thank you thank you beverly amazing
we've obviously got a gift for you but i
don't know what it is
hey bills
oh lovely
oh
oh she's a pippin fan
billy she must be scottish look at her
hair
hey we should eat the world we've got no
time one question and then eat the word
okay you said one question
wait beverly get out of there beverly
for god's sake
you've already won the
whole podcast all right sorry beverly
don't worry it's only online hello hi
i'm paulina i'm from chicago hi um
being that this is a podcast about
friendship one of the first things we
ask our new friends as a litmus test is
what
tim curry movie
uh you recognize like what which movie
do you associate with tim curry what's
the first one oh wow
i don't like being part of a litmus test
come
um
what a great actor
in a lot of different
like forms as well a great a great
musical actor as well curry tim curry as
well as a great character actor and a
scary actor
i'm gonna i'm gonna mention three things
and i'm gonna like isolate one
legend was the first thing
okay that i saw him in and he's
legitimately terrifying as the kind of
devil
character in legend
rocky horror picture show is
an incredible film across the board
absolutely fantastic but for me the
thing that i identify with
tim curry the most is probably clue
he's just so mad cap and so
he runs that whole thing it's it's a
film
completely existing out of control and
one of the few things that is in control
even though he's not really handling it
is the butler is tim curry and he's so
fantastic in that film really do you
know something i've noticed over the 20
years that we've known each other
if anybody asks you for one thing
you always give them three or four
it's true it's really hard for me to
double down on anything but i'm glad you
answered first because i was going to
say edward scissorhands because i
thought you were talking about that
director what's his name oh tim burn
yeah that's something totally different
rocky horror pictures yo
just so you know you're both past the
litmus litmus test thank you
well listen we're gonna eat the world
let's see the world we only have five
minutes
eat the world
we've brought a chica would you say
chicago in is that right oh chicago
chicago what do people from chicago was
chicago called what's that what are they
called
chicago wins right we've got a chicago
thing bro chicago in staple which is the
whole assault and sweet popcorn thing
but what's it you you had it a second
ago
has everybody got some people right
they're allowed to open them now
but not eat them yet only open and smell
i was saying to billy get it here
i'm starving what is this for the two of
us yeah i was saying to billy
i was lucky enough one time
to
oh hello
i was lucky enough one time to have been
invited to a kind of
uh
kind of gifting suite where they kind of
give out free stuff you know
it's usually kind of
like nonsense stuff like you know
shampoo and conditioner and moisturizer
and stuff and every so often you get
stuff where you think oh
it's quite good like headphones or
popcorn and one time i was given
a gallon
two gallon actually size bucket
of this popcorn the whole cheesy caramel
popcorn and i had to throw it out
halfway through
because i liked it so much
that i would come downstairs and before
breakfast i would be like well i'll just
have a three or four mouthfuls and that
would be my breakfast which is not
recommended bills but anyway let me tell
you about it yeah please i'll have a
mouthful the salt and sweet mixture is a
staple in the city particularly around
the holidays thanks to garrett popcorn
known clickable ukulele as in locally
as garrett's
which has been serving up gourmet
popcorn and downtown chicago for over 70
years the popcorn chain is now a windy
city institution but its origins
actually can be traced back to milwaukee
where the garrett family held a
competition to see who could make the
most delicious caramel corn
that burst the recipe now known in the
stores as caramel crisp which officially
made its debut when the family moved to
chicago and opened their first door in
the loop on madison and state in
1949 try that right here we go
you know what i think
what i think you guys do
in america in the united states of
america better than anyone else
because
there are other places in the world
where there are certain flavor
combinations that i prefer
there are places that do spicy better
there are places that do
rice dishes better or obviously pasta
bear what you guys do better than anyone
else on the planet is a combination of
sweet and savory i think you guys do
that better than anyone else the whole
peanut butter and jelly
the whole
caramel corn and cheese
yeah
i know
you guys like to do you know that whole
like sometimes you'll
you'll add like a a honey to a bacon or
a maple syrup to a bacon or a
marshmallow to a sweet potato and
initially you're like wait what that's
weird but the great thing about you guys
as a country is you're like yeah we
don't have to explain ourselves it
tastes good
try it and it does taste good and we are
trying it it's fantastic
and movie theaters in britain you can
get salty and you can get sweet popcorn
and i always ask somebody to do 50 50.
and that's exactly what this says give
us a question while we're eating come on
would you hang out with us
so hi i'm uh tony from wisconsin
and uh on the sweet question uh this
one's been keeping me up for
you know three o'clock four o'clock for
the past couple nights uh is the
gingerbread man made of house or is his
house made of flesh
good question
that's profound
what'd you think
my god
[Laughter]
that's so tasty as well
god almighty
i think that well the gingerbread man is
the first thing right surely they didn't
create a gingerbread house and then go
gingerbread well maybe
well he must have been in a gingerbread
horse bottle
right he must have been born to a
gingerbread parents but didn't they live
in a gingerbread house
and was there a gingerbread doctor right
i
mean that's an extremely profound and
confusing question can we get back to
you on that one yeah again
well we'll answer that a different
thanks for stomping us
now it's a good one though it's because
it's like a modern day chicken in the
egg thing isn't it dom
let's give it some scores really are we
done should we get one more question
because let's go yeah that's what i mean
come on let's get one more question what
does everybody think of this anyway yeah
is everyone eating it is everyone
enjoying it you guys i'm sure you guys
are all used to it good
hmm
i don't want chocolate i don't want
chocolate on my fingers when i'm eating
popcorn
i think you have a little popcorn fork
i don't want that
william
there's a young lady over there i'm
sorry
what's your name and where'd you come
from um i'm katherine and i am from
grand rapids michigan
michigan yeah
do you know the do you know the german
town yes frankenmuth
um so my question is is with most pg-13
movies you can sneak in the word [ __ ] so
um if you could sneak in the word [ __ ]
for one of your lines of lord of the
rings uh which one would it be
[Applause]
it's a great question we've explored
this a couple of times have you seen a
t-shirt
yeah
what's up ladies have you worn wedge
i saw one the other day what made me
laugh it's not a line from mary but it's
just
it is a line in the film it's a line
from frodo at the very end of returning
a king
instead of what we hear in the actual
film frodo just leans towards sam and
says
go on sam
give uh rosie
no no
i quite like that yeah
yeah anyway
you need people of intelligence
on this sort of
[ __ ]
mission
quest
[Applause]
thing
brilliant
thank you
while we get while we get ready to wrap
up here and give scores i'm going to say
one more thing about this amazing
popcorn that read now which is from
uh the garrett is from garrett.com so i
said there is nothing like this sweet
and salty combination
says a spokesman from garrett.com
it's a great surprise once you taste it
who knew that the real wisconsin cheddar
cheese and wholemeal caramel would be so
delicious together there's a bit of a
badge of honor that comes from being the
one who introduced a garrett mix to
another they'll remember that gift
forever so will you remember that we had
this in chicago i certainly will i've
had it i've had it before but i don't
think you have right
and it is absolutely fantastic very
moorish all right we'll give it some
scores do you have a question sir we'll
give it some scores while we give it uh
while we answer this question my name is
jane i'm from chicago hey
bro i was wondering and the extended
series uh um sorry i'm kind of nervous
you know you're gonna give me the two
towers movie um
the orc um one of the aurora guy um
feeds mary uh grog and i was wondering
what did they use to um
chug you down with that grog what do
they use
oh
so so tasty is popcorn
we've been asking this question a lot
and
i actually struggled for an answer
so i reached out to mark odesky who was
one of the producers of the film a few
months ago just after he came on our
podcast i said mark do you happen to
know
what billy and i would were drinking
were forced to drink by the urukai
because
it's kind of slipped my mind i i would
guess but it wouldn't be right
mark odesky got back in touch with me
and you said it was as far as they know
from the crew a combination of prune
juice
and flat
fizzy soda
so
so i'm assuming
maybe let's say for the sake of argument
a flat coca-cola that's been shaken up
and all the fizz has come out of it
mixed with prune juice so you're getting
yeah you're getting a sickly sweet kind
of thing
but with a little bit of
and i'm going to use one of my favorite
words here
viscosity
thank you hey should we give it some
scores
bills
flavor taste and or flavor
hell i'm gonna say
it's a 10 out of 10.
not been many others i'll give it a 9.9
[ __ ] it is amazing we're going out
for dinner with sean elijah tonight and
i'm going to have no appetite so i'm
going to stop now right i'm not
aesthetics the look of the tin and the
look of the popcorn
but also the look of the tin you've got
a bright yellow
with a kind of deep caramel oh oh god
it's rather rather unattractive
[Laughter]
but like three times as tasty
um
yeah it's a it's a great tin and it's a
great look i'm going to give it an 8 out
of 10. well no wonder dom because that's
lovely isn't it
and then the picture of chicago on the
run the the birthplace of modern
architecture
and um and in the fireworks i've got to
give that
a nine oh it's a nine is it and then
your favorite category
usefulness is it useful wait just before
we answer is it useful let's have our
final question of the evening
ah
hello and your wonderful rainbow tie
over there what's your name and did you
come from um my name is nicole and i'm
from the chicago area oh hello from the
chicago area um my questions kind of
specifically for dom oh good stay out of
it right
so
not everybody may know that you're also
a poet
and so i'm kind of cheating a little bit
but um
i wrote sort of a
thank you
slash
poem
sort of
for you specifically for all of the
poetry that you share on your social
media
and i wondered whether or not i could
give it to you oh well you can would you
like to read it or is that too intimate
i mean i could but
i still want to give it to you well i
would of course like to receive it if
you would like to read it out please but
if you'd rather not read it out then
that's fine too it's whatever you want
to do
i can read it okay come on
[Music]
who doesn't want to end the show with a
poem
um
does it start with um
no but i'm going to read the title first
from one poet to another
in the echo chamber void of isolation
downtime and internet wormholes watching
conspiracy theories and misinformation
news stories chase each other like an
endless awards
lost in the space between heartbeats
shattered by a sea of scattered pixels
your poetry is the lifeblood i seek
this promise of mutual humanity
a whispered defibrillation sparked by
inspiration and imagery rhythm and
vocabulary
this snapshot of a mental process shared
with the world in polaroid
sincerity whether it's the ghost in your
heart
a feather of floating in a glass jar
or a crush
leaving the party with an umbrella and a
coat made of trestle and starlight
there's kinship in the details beacons
in the space between syllables
and taking my breath away
you remind me
to inhale
all that space thank you
thank you so much
lovely
um
what love can i can i is that a gift i'd
love to receive a gift yeah
thank you so much
that's very sweet
thank you it's very kind
um well i mean
i love writing poetry it's my all-time
favorite thing to do as someone artistic
and if anyone
recognizes any element of what i do as a
poet it's it resonates super strong so
thank you so much for that it's very
kind hey bills usefulness
how useful is a salty and sweet popcorn
well you can bring it to the cinema in
your own right or they won't allow you
and really
or you can stuff it in your pockets
maybe yeah yeah
sneak
if you had just like that in your
cupboard and like uh
um a bag of flour all-purpose not
self-raising
a bar of chocolate some marshmallows and
an egg
could you do something yeah
you could make a casserole out of it so
it's useful could you like um
was it in a blender and then put it on
top of ice cream
i was gonna say if you if you smash that
into like pulverized pieces yeah it's
actually nothing and then put it on top
of ice cream and freeze it then you get
a little scoop of it on your ice cream
or on a cake or in cookies
i mean it's very i think it's pretty
versatile
i'm gonna in terms of usefulness
i'm gonna give it an eight out of ten
that's quite good
um and you sold me on that don't
i will also give it an eight
it's a high high score high high high
high high
high high scores garrett's popcorn
fantastic billy and i are going to fight
over who takes that home uh well it's me
it was great food
this has been the quote-unquote most
intimate
uh
friendship onion podcast that we've had
so far and we absolutely appreciate all
you guys coming hopefully you guys are
gonna be around for the weekend we look
forward to seeing you there
thank you very much for coming it's very
cool with you guys and uh hopefully this
kicks off a really fun
really exciting convention weekend for
you guys and if in any way billy and i
can make that more special for you guys
outside of cash
right
we're more than happy to do that
thanks a lot for coming fantastic thank
you
[Applause]
thank you have a great we'll see you
over the weekend see you over the
weekend bye-bye thanks for coming to the
friendship onion
[Music]
on my pearl